what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar
and here i am back at it again to
discuss the latest
craziest developments in the one piece
story we got some truly epic moments in
this one
so make sure to stay tuned for that if
you do enjoy seeing these one-piece
chapter reviews and want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button to let me know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future one piece videos
and while you impatiently wait for the
next chapter to drop feel free to check
out my growing one piece playlist where
you can find videos about the yonko
warlord supernovas and more
link in description and feel free to
leave some suggestions for future video
topics
in the comments below now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and all this chapter is called please
let us die a pretty intriguing title to
say the least
and we'll see who exactly is referring
to as we read on but i must say
i enjoy reading the titles without
context only to later see
how they fit into the chapter yet
another thing oda does well and they
don't usually mention the cover stories
but in this case we have
pound hugging lola and chiffon for the
first time in 26 years and just
bawling his eyes out like what a
freaking touching moment that we've been
building up to and that's only the cover
story you can feel the joy in this panel
and i literally get emotional when i
actually take the time to look at it
another sign of oda's genius and it's
not even the main story
well played sir well played so last
chapter we got drake revealing that he
wants to team up with luffy
and he also took down one of the ancient
giants aka one of the numbers
here we have people reacting and being
confused by what's going on
our guys there guys everyone is like why
attack
the numbers drake even page 1 is saying
it seemingly not wanting to believe it
again we get a flashback to kobe talking
to drake which i enjoy
kobe is hype and he explains that luffy
is very close
when you are his friend but if you're an
enemy he will be out of your reach
he is that kind of person and again
luffy's power to attract people is
mentioned and mihawk mentioned this
during the paramount war
saying it was luffy's most dangerous
power luffy has something about him that
makes people want to help him
and here it's coming up again you
probably can't pinpoint it to any one
thing
but one of the things i love about luffy
is how straightforward he is
so many people are manipulative and
machiavellian while there is never
really another side with luffy or an
ulterior motive
what you see is what you get and i think
people are drawn to this kind of honesty
especially when it's surrounded by
people
constantly trying to manipulate you and
luffy is again very straightforward with
drake
saying that he's seen him before and
asking if he wants to defeat kaido
most people wouldn't expect people to
honestly answer that question
but luffy seems super trusting and in
his defense he did just have kaido's
daughter join forces with him so a
flying six-member
is not even that shocking by comparison
the funny thing is that drake
is not helping his case he says that he
can't tell luffy why
but their objective is the same very
mysterious very
unclear response zorro has a more
natural reaction assuming that drake is
using the confusion
in order to try to trick luffy while
he's actually working for kaido like
hawkins
almost everyone seems suspicious of
drake understandably so
but luffy just says it's okay he will
join as an ally
and i love that we got the captain
calling the shots and luffy being luffy
and what more could you ask for
sure luffy gets called an idiot captain
but at the end of the day they're gonna
respect his wishes and accept drake for
now
as that happens we get some page one and
ulti time which i enjoy
seeing the samurai plan to stop these
two flying six members from reaching
luffy which is honorable and respectable
but alas
they don't really stand a chance if they
go for luffy in their dino zone
transformations they'll
make it through the samurai with no
issue luffy recognizes them and then we
get what i've been waiting for
sanji finally spotted ulti and with red
cheeks he says
who's that cutie next to the dinosaur
from the flower capital
of course sanji would be all over this
dino cutie
and i really look forward to how that
dynamic will develop moving forward the
two dino people have no intention of
letting luffy near kaido again
but then our boy usop comes to rescue
along with nami
and they not only come in clutch with
the lizard repellent smoke
they also bring comedy and usefulness
with them they distract ulti
and page 1 and make it easier for luffy
to reach his goal of getting to kaido as
soon as possible
when you distract the toby ropo that's
useful because enough opponents like
that could significantly slow luffy down
so the fact that nami and usop
distracted them despite the fact that
they're probably scared and not
expecting to beat flying six members is
a significant win
as ulti is wondering who hit her
precious paypay
she looks to nami looking stoic and
pretty badass while usopp hides behind
her after launching the attack
nami is not too happy with usopp hiding
behind her but she knows the drill by
now
she says the fight has begun here we go
and of course
just as it seems like nami might stand
and fight she uses the joestar family
secret technique
which involves running away as she runs
for her life with a worried expression
on her face
she says bring it on and usopp mentions
what we're all thinking how her words
don't match her actions at all
again we get the humor among the crew
and the characters we love
and we also have oda having fun with the
conventions of cool anime speeches while
subverting it by having nami run away
and of course it's hilarious that usopp
would say this in the first place
because his words usually don't match
his actions at all since as we know
he likes telling tall tales the point is
though together they succeed in
infuriating ulti and the flying six
members proceed to chase them freeing up
luffy and sanji to keep running to where
kinemon and the others are
and then we get the return of apoo who
is definitely not one of my favorite
supernovas but he is tricky
luffy tells sanji to cover his ears to
avoid the damage of the fighting music
still apoo says they won't escape the
silent fight we got a shot of three
numbers
and the ancient giants are still down
for the count apu is upset
that they look so pitiful now when they
destroyed so many villages
he even cries complaining that it's not
fun to be attacked while drinking at a
great feast
but you gotta expect that as a pirate
especially if you're one as two-faced
lazapoo
again we are reminded of apu's nice
bounty of 350 million berries
he speaks to hacha behind him and
proclaims that he is about to show our
guys
what happens when the ancient giants
truly go wild
the threat of the numbers is definitely
not done yet and hacha is even seemingly
preparing to use his own fellow number
as a weapon
the samurai are shocked by the display
of power but sanji urges luffy not to
stop because if he does
there is no end of opponents and luffy
agrees just like at marineford
he doesn't have time to be distracted by
fighting strong opponents
while jinbei tells us that every number
is a threat frankie comments that he
doesn't have enough cola to deal with so
many
since there are supposed to be 10. and
hilariously enough the best strategy
is to distract again as hacha views
frankie's cool
armor like a toy and wants it jinbei
thinking quickly tells frankie to hop
out of the dome since the samurai won't
stand a chance against the number
running
wild the plan seems to be working well
and frankie plans to make hotshot regret
treating the great general frankie like
a toy
although you gotta admit he does look
like a toy albeit
a really epic one zorro andre keep
fighting since zoro doesn't really trust
him yet
but as apu is trying to call more
numbers we get to see these two cool
characters team up against him
building some trust there and it's nice
to see apu scrambling and in trouble
and as if we needed more reasons to like
drake he also says that he hated abu
since the beginning
and that he's gonna crush him for his
own sake zoro agrees and we seem to have
a growing understanding between these
two now
and i really do like the alliance
between these two supernovas
specifically but it can't be that easy
apu keeps getting lucky and
queen straight up starts firing bullets
from a machine gun
suggesting that drake shouldn't for a
second think that he'll be allowed to
escape
he calls him a traitor and then corrects
himself to spy
since he wasn't truly loyal to kaido
from the beginning at first drake seems
unfazed
wondering why queen would think bullets
would hurt him but then he wonders about
the bullet
suggesting that there could be more to
it it could contain
sea stone or could be poisoned since
biological warfare
would definitely not be a surprise for
kaido's crew at this point
whatever it is they're not normal
bullets we can rest assured of that
and queen knows what he's doing on the
roof we straight up see an all-star
namely
jack getting his tusk cut off and he
falls
clearly overpowered by his opponents he
looks straight up defeated which is a
shock to me in the sense that i thought
the fight would be shown more on screen
and not just the end result by doing it
this way oda seems to be hyping up the
power of sulong nekomamushi and
inuarashi even more
as if he's saying the fight wasn't even
close so why bother showing it
now i'm all the more hyped to see these
two in action
the point is though even without luffy
there yet
our samurai are doing well really well
kaido straight up says that jack is
all-star and his precious men
are being killed jack apologizes to
kaido but kaido explains it's not
because he's weak
it's because the tsulong inuarashi and
nekomamushi are just way too
strong which is so hype coming from
iyanko
what's interesting is how much kaido is
recognizing the strength of his opponent
and how caring and understanding he
seems to be concerning his men here i
love learning about kaido because there
always seems to be more that meets the
eye with him
he clearly isn't just a survival of the
fittest if you lose you die kind of
leader
he actually calls his men precious and
he comforts jack
very interesting stuff and he definitely
seems like a better leader
now than i expected him to be at first
yeah jack
will probably get up again at some point
but i don't see him being much of a
threat moving forward
and that's saying a lot since he's
supposed to be one of kaido's strongest
men kaido lets us know that the sulong
plan
was effective and they caused a lot of
damage
but they couldn't do more than that and
then he tells jack to go heal up
implying that he'll be just fine long
term kinemon then thanks the mink
warriors
and then goes on to straight up cut
through kaido's heat blast
and when he was first introduced as a
fire cutter who would have thought
that he'd go on to use it so effectively
and epically
against a yonko of all people this
moment is definitely the pinnacle of
such an ability and i believe oda
handled it very nicely here
he appears to hit kaido with his slash
to the yonko's shock
again kaido is showing significant
vulnerability before luffy and the
others have even showed up the samurai
make it clear
that they're not looking to escape from
kaido they want to die here as
lord odin samurai and they will take
kaido with them
i also love that ezo is shown so there
are still nine red scabbards facing
kaido
even after kanjuro's betrayal again
kaido looks concerned this ain't a walk
in the park for him or he would have
taken them all out
before they could hurt so many of his
precious men this
is intense but it's good that these
characters are prepared to die
since i can't see them or at least all
of them leaving this battle with their
lives
sure things are going super well right
now but this is a yonko in front of them
and he's definitely gonna pull off some
things worthy of his title of strongest
creature in the world
the counter-offensive will be
significant and it seems like queen and
king
haven't really even started trying yet
nor has big mom and we'll see how that
turns out but
wow we are fast approaching some big
twists and loss
as i can feel it at the same time though
we're definitely seeing more and more
of the road map to kaido's eventual
defeat if not his death
i love seeing the red scabbers get their
chance to shine
because they have earned it and sulong
nekomamushi and inuarashi
are especially epic right now as they
take down an all-star
before the scene even jumps back to them
aesthetic wise they look amazing too and
that's all i can say right now i really
look forward to the next chapter and
learning more about kaido and his powers
and seeing how everyone else fares in
their own individual fights
we're seeing that even though one piece
is so far into the story
the power scaling is still great because
everyone is still playing a significant
role in the war
kaido even if he's a yonko can't just
take all the opponents out by himself
and luffy our protagonist also clearly
needs help and is getting it
as long as the power remains well
balanced like this i think one piece
will continue to be absolutely
fascinating
and that is it for this video let me
know what you thought of this chapter
and what you expect to happen next
if you do enjoy these one piece chapter
reviews and want to keep them coming the
best you can do is smash that like
button to let me know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe this
is crucial hit that notification bell
and select
all or you will miss future one-piece
videos and while you impatiently wait
for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist where you can find videos
about the yonko warlord supernovas and
more
link in description and in the comments
you can leave any suggestions for videos
you are burning up to see thanks again
and until next time see ya space cowboys
you